El pasado mes de mayo de 2023, la economía
norteamericana volvió a estar en la cuerda
floja.
A punto de alcanzarse el techo de la deuda
y con acuerdo entre la Casa Blanca y el Congreso
que se demoró más de la cuenta, el gobierno
federal estuvo muy cerca del default.
Os hablamos de ello con todo detalle en nuestro
canal hermano, VisualEconomik.
Las consecuencias podrían haber sido catastróficas.
N1 (11 de mayo, 2023: Janet Yellen dice que
el impago de EEUU desencadenaría una recesión
económica mundial)
Sin embargo, finalmente la sangre no llegó
al río.
El 27 de mayo el presidente Biden anunció
un acuerdo con el bloque republicano del Congreso
para ampliar el límite de endeudamiento del
gobierno federal.
Entonces, ¿Todo arreglado?
¿Pueden los Estados Unidos volver a estar
tranquilos?
¿El peligro ya se ha terminado?
Pues…
Lo siento pero NO.
Tal y como podéis ver, con ampliación del
techo de la deuda o sin ella, Estados Unidos
sigue uno de los países con mayor relación
PIB-Deuda de todo el mundo.
Y no solo eso, la economía norteamericana
se enfrentará en las próximas décadas a
un riesgo mucho mayor.
Y por eso en VisualPolitik nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Puede el tío Sam llegar a incumplir sus
deudas?
¿Cuántas veces ha ocurrido esto en el pasado?
¿Todo se arregla ampliando el techo de la
deuda?
¿Cómo de sólidas son las costuras fiscales
del gobierno de los Estados Unidos de América?
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
[Aunque antes de ir con eso, fijáos en esta
gráfica:¿Sabíais que prácticamente 9 de
cada diez suscriptores de VisualPolitik todavía
no estáis suscritos a VisualEconomik?
VisualEconomik es nuestro canal hermano.
En él tratamos temas top de la economía.
¿Y sabéis qué?
(Estamos seguro de que os va a gustar.
En VisualEconomik os hablamos de temas tan
interesantes como los constantes bloqueos
de Francia al desarrollo económico de Europa,
como Israel o Taiwán han logrado convertirse
en superpotencias tecnológicas.
Y por supuesto, también abordamos muchos
de los grandes debates económicos del momento.
Así que, si todavía no estás suscrito,
no esperes más, te dejamos el link en la
descripción.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, si bien todos reconocemos
que la economía norteamericana es todo un
coloso, de vez en cuando, algunos episodios
como la crisis del 2008, o las constantes
amenazas de que el gobierno se quede sin dinero
generan muchas dudas.
La última crisis del techo de la deuda y
el posible cataclismo que podría haber supuesto
el default de una economía cuya moneda es
con mucha diferencia, la principal reserva
de valor de todo el mundo, es un buen ejemplo.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, porque lo
cierto es que todo este tema de la deuda,
los descuadres presupuestarios e, incluso,
los defaults, no es algo precisamente nuevo.
Ya en su discurso de despedida, el mismísimo
George Washington dedicó buena parte de sus
palabras para alertar a sus sucesores del
riesgo que un descuadre financiero podría
suponer.
Fijaos en estas palabras del 19 de septiembre
de 1796.
C1(“El crédito público es una fuente muy
importante de fuerza y seguridad.
Un método para preservarlo consiste en utilizarlo
con la mayor moderación posible (…) no
sólo evitando ocasiones de gasto, sino realizando
vigorosos esfuerzos en tiempos de paz para
saldar las deudas que las guerras inevitables
puedan haber ocasionado, no arrojando sin
generosidad sobre la posteridad la carga que
nosotros mismos deberíamos soportar.”
George Washington, en su discurso de despedida
de la presidencia.
19 septiembre de 1796.)
Desde entonces y sin importar su signo político,
prácticamente todos los presientes han dicho
preocuparse por el enorme riesgo que supone
una creciente deuda pública.
Y, sin embargo, pese a todas estas buenas
palabras, lo cierto es que la deuda ha seguido
creciendo más y más, sin freno.
Desde 1940 el techo de la deuda se ha ampliado
unas 90 veces…
Es decir, algo más de una vez por año…
Que se dice pronto.
Algo que pone sobre la mesa la primera conclusión:
el techo de la deuda, en la práctica, no
sirve para nada.
Ni siquiera a conseguido evitar que presidente
tras presidente, todos echen mano de la inagotable
tarjeta de crédito del gobierno federal.
La pregunta, ¿por qué demonios todos los
presidentes de Estados Unidos parecen enganchados
a la deuda?
¿Hacia dónde se dirige el país?
¿Ha llegado el momento del ajuste fiscal?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Vamos con ello.
T1(TECHO SI, CONTROL NO)
Como ya os contamos en nuestro canal hermano
VisualEconomik, el ahora conocido como “techo
de la deuda” fue un mecanismo de control
que entró en vigor en el año 1917.
Hasta ese momento cualquier préstamo que
tomará el tesoro tenía que ser explícitamente
autorizado por el Congreso.
Para hacer este procedimiento mucho más sencillo
y, al mismo tiempo, seguir controlando al
gobierno federal, los políticos norteamericanos
se secaron de la manga esta herramienta: un
límite claro y conocido al endeudamiento
que el gobierno federal puede asumir.
Es decir, era una especie de doble control.
Por un lado, el Congreso aprueba los presupuestos,
pero por otro impide que el gobierno federal
se endeude más de la cuenta.
Con lo que se supone que a la hora de preparar
el presupuesto tendría que tener este límite
muy en cuenta.
Sin embargo, hecha la ley, hecha la trampa.
Año tras año la Casa Blanca de turno se
las fue arreglando para incrementar cada vez
más el techo de la deuda.
Al final lo que nació como un límite se
convirtió en poco más que una pesada broma.
Fijaos.
(Tal y como podéis ver, el techo de 1940,
fijado en unos 49 mil millones de USD hoy
no es más que un insignificante punto en
un gráfico que refleja de forma muy visual
el voraz apetitivo de el gobierno norteamericano.
Para finales de la Segunda Guerra Mun dial
el techo si había quintuplicado.
Y a partir de hasta los años 80 este límite
se duplicó prácticamente cada década.)
Claro que, un momento, porque esto tiene algo
de trampa.
Es verdad que la deuda del gobierno federal
ha crecido como un cohete, sin embargo, si
nos fijamos en la relación deuda/PIB no ha
ocurrido lo mismo.
O al menos no lo hizo durante décadas.
De hecho, en los 80 la deuda federal llegó
a ser tan baja como un 31,7%
El problema del techo de la deuda es que a
la hora de la verdad no sirve para nada excepto
para generar tensión.
Si los presupuestos son deficitarios y el
gobierno se tiene que endeudar, el techo de
la deuda ha demostrado ser un mecanismo completamente
inútil, excepto, insisto, para generar mucha
tensión política y por extensión también
económica.
Por eso, hacia 1970, el representante republicano
Dick [guéfardt] Gephardt impulsó la "Regla
Gephardt", por la cual se entendía que si
el Congreso había aprobado un presupuesto
que perforaba el techo de la deuda, automáticamente
aprobaba la ampliación de este último.
Para que os hagáis una idea, cuando esta
regla entró en vigor el techo era de unos
830 mil millones de dólares.
Y cuando fue derogada finalmente en 1995,
el techo ya estaba en los 5,5 billones.
Desde entonces, cada vez que la deuda se aproxima
a este límite estalla la polémica y no pocas
veces la guerra entre la Casa Blanca y el
Congreso.
Eso sí, al final siempre se termina moviendo
hacia arriba.
2023 ha sido un buen ejemplo.
Y es que, en realidad, el techo de la deuda
es solo una cara de la moneda.
Me explico, es evidente que no habría deuda
si no hubiera un gasto excesivo, o al menos,
un nivel de gasto por encima de los ingresos
del propio gobierno.
Pero, ¿hasta dónde llega exactamente el
problema?
¿Realmente tenemos motivos para preocuparnos?
¿Hasta qué punto la Casa Blanca es adicta
a la deuda?
Pues…
Atentos.
T2(UNA CHEQUERA FUERA DE CONTROL)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, seguramente
la inmensa mayoría de los que estáis viendo
este vídeo, tengáis alguna deuda pendiente:
la tarjeta de crédito, la hipoteca, un préstamo
comercial para compraros un coche, lo que
sea.
Y a ver, eso no es nada malo, incluso podría
llegar a ser algo bueno.
Podríamos, por ejemplo, pedir dinero prestado
para abrir un negocio o comprar un activo
que nos pueda dar rentabilidad.
Y, en cualquier caso, sea para lo que sea,
si podemos permitirnos con nuestros ingresos
el pago de los intereses y la devolución
de la propia deuda, entonces no habrá ningún
problema.
Lo malo es cuando todo esto se va a al garete.
Cuando asumimos tal cantidad de deuda que
los números ya no salen.
Pues bien, algo así es lo que le ha ocurrido
al gobierno federal de Estados Unidos.
Un gobierno que vive con un enorme cañón
presupuestario permanente.
Prácticamente, cada año que pasa los cheques
que salen de la Casa Blanca son cada vez más
y más grandes.
Y esto es así, incluso, en términos constantes.
Fijaos.
Y la pregunta que podemos hacernos es: ¿Dónde
va a parar todo este dinero?
Y sí, ya sé lo que muchos estáis pensando:
obvio Alberto, a defensa.
Estados Unidos gasta toneladas de dinero en
armas y soldados.
¿Verdad?
Pues no, lo cierto es que esa no es ni de
lejos la causa principal.
De hecho, en dólares constantes el gasto
militar no ha crecido tanto.
Lleva casi 20 años prácticamente estancado.
Fijaos:
Pero, ¿entonces?
¿Por qué en Estados Unidos crece tanto el
gasto público año tras año?
¿A dónde va a parar todo ese dinero?
Pues lo cierto, amigos es que la situación
en este caso no es muy diferente a la de Europa.
La inmensa mayor parte del incremento presupuestario
tiene una explicación que podemos resumir
en dos palabras: gasto social.
Ahora bien, un momento, durante años más
o menos a pesar de esta evolución, lo cierto
es que el gasto del gobierno federal en términos
de PIB se mantuvo más o menos estable.
Es decir, la economía crecía, el gobierno
ingresaba más y entonces dirigía la inmensa
mayor parte de todos esos recursos al gasto
social.
Incluso, también, reducía la inversión
en otras partidas.
Por ejemplo, ¿alguna vez habéis oído hablar
de lo mal que están las infraestructuras
en Estados Unidos?
Pues eso.
El problema es que en los últimos años ese
método ya no parece suficiente.
Así que el gasto público en términos de
PIB también se ha disparado.
Desde que arrancara el siglo XXI, el gasto
del gobierno federal ha pasado de entorno
al 18% a más del 30% del PIB.
Incluso sin contar la pandemia es muy posible
que el gasto público estaría hoy por encima
del 24% o el 25%
Pero ese, ese no es el mayor problema.
El mayor problema es que ese nivel de gasto
siempre ha estado soportado por un enorme
déficit...
Un boquete presupuestario que en 2023 estará
por encima del 5% del PIB y que está haciendo
que la deuda pública crezca como un cohete.
Un momento, ¿pensáis que exageramos?
¿Cómo un cohete?
Pues…
Fijaos.
Pero esto no ha hecho más que empezar.
Estos son los datos y las proyecciones de
la oficina presupuestaria del Congreso.
Cómo podéis ver, se espera que en términos
de PIB el peso de la deuda federal pase de
entorno al 100% hoy a casi el 200% en los
próximos 30 años.
Y todo esto pese a que la recaudación del
gobierno está prácticamente en niveles récord.
Amigos, hasta ahora el gobierno de Estados
Unidos ha tenido una enorme ventaja: como
el dólar es la moneda de reserva internacional,
la demanda de deuda pública del gobierno
federal es enorme.
Eso les ha perimido incrementar tanto su deuda
sin que se disparen los tipos de interés.
Algo que ha provocado situaciones como esta.
N2 (1 de agosto de 2011: Putin acusa a Estados
Unidos de vivir "como un parásito de la economía
global" EuropaPress)
Por supuesto, eso no tiene nada que ver con
la realidad.
Pero sea como sea la pregunta, es ¿hasta
cuando puede durar semejante globo?
¿Realmente es sostenible semejante camino?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(T3: EL PEOR DE LOS AUGURIOS…
¿ES POSIBLE UN DEFAULT?)
Amigos, el gran boquete presupuestario que
está destrozando las finanzas públicas del
gobierno federal, del gobierno federal de
Estados Unidos - y de muchos otros países
del mundo, por cierto - tiene nombres y apellidos:
es la Seguridad Social.
El progresivo envejecimiento de la población
supone un gran desafío.
Hasta ahora Estados Unidos ha podido evitar
el tema…
Pero, ¿lo podrá seguir evitando durante
mucho más tiempo?
(En el sistema de seguridad social norteamericano
los ingresos actuales no llegan a cubrir las
pensiones comprometidas por el gobierno.
Sin embargo, año tras año este sistema cierra
en números positivos gracias sobre todo al
Fondo de Jubilación y Sobrevivientes y el
Fondo de Discapacidad.
Dos fondos que se crearon en los años 1939
y 1956 respectivamente para acumular dinero
para hacer frente a los futuros pagos de la
Seguridad Social.
Porque sí, en Estados Unidos, a diferencia
de otros países, sí que se ha ahorrado para
la jubilación.
A finales de 2022 estos dos fondos tenían
activos ahorrados por valor de 2,9 billones
de dólares.)
El problema es que se espera que estos fondos
se agoten en unos años.
Según las últimas proyecciones podemos contemplar
tres escenarios posibles.
Pues bien, incluso en el mejor escenario que
se imagina, estos fondos apenas durarían
unos 15 o 16 años.
En el peor, podrían agotarse en menos de
una década.
Es decir, que a partir de ese momento, al
gobierno le tocará tirar de más y más y
más de deuda.
Y, ojo, porque ese es solo el primer gran
desafío que la Casa Blanca tendrá que empezar
a tomarse muy en serio a partir de ahora.
Es el primero, pero no es el único.
Por otro lado, la enorme deuda que ya ha contraído
el tío Sam naturalmente obliga a pagar intereses.
En 2022, por ejemplo, el gobierno ya tuvo
desembolsar casi 400 mil millones de dólares
solo para pagar los intereses.
Y claro, con tipos al alza, todo apunta a
que esta cifra seguirá creciendo.
Y no solo serán los intereses, el gasto social
también continuará creciendo y para colmo
la creciente rivalidad con China y la experiencia
en Ucrania están haciendo que los políticos
de Washington quieran impulsar el gasto militar.
En otras palabras, que en el Departamento
del Tesoro van a tener que hacer malabares
para lidiar con tanto gasto.
Y, ojo, porque aquí un cambio de gobierno
difícilmente arreglará algo.
En las últimas décadas, el mayor acuerdo
bipartito en Estados Unidos ha sido que no
pasa nada por gastar cada vez más.
En 2023 hemos visto cómo la falta de acuerdo
para ampliar el techo de la deuda estuvo a
punto de provocar un default.
Lo que disparó todas las alarmas.
Se arregló con una patada para adelante que
básicamente retrasa el problema.
Pero este será un tema que cada vez estará
más sobre la mesa.
La condición de refugio del dólar hace que
sea casi impensable pensar en que Estados
Unidos pueda suspender pagos…
Salvo por un desacuerdo político.
Pero, el propio dominio del dólar se basa
en la confianza en la economía norteamericana
y, también, en la salud de las finanzas públicas
del gobierno.
La primera en general va bien, la segunda
de mal en peor.
No será hoy, y quizás tampoco mañana, pero
tarde o temprano y mejor antes que después
en Washington tendrán que buscar una solución.
Durante décadas han podido vivir con un boquete
presupuestario crónico, pero este no deja
de crecer y ya se está haciendo demasiado
grande.
Amigos la economía norteamericana va razonablemente
bien, pero los políticos de Washington no
están cumpliendo con su parte.
Y eso hace que a medio plazo muchos analistas
no descarten que las cosas se pongan mucho
más tensas.
Especialmente teniendo en cuenta que en unos
años las pensiones también tendrán que
financiarse con deuda.
Todavía hay tiempo, pero esta bomba fiscal
es sin duda otra de las grandes amenazas a
las que se enfrenta Estados Unidos.
C2 (“Un impago no tendría precedentes y
podría ser catastrófico: los mercados de
crédito podrían congelarse, el valor del
dólar podría desplomarse, los tipos de interés
estadounidenses podrían dispararse, los efectos
negativos podrían repercutir en todo el mundo
y podría producirse una crisis financiera
y una recesión que podrían ser un eco de
los acontecimientos de 2008 o algo peor.”
The potential macroeconomic effect of debt
ceiling brinkmanship - U.S.
Department of the Treasury, October 2013.)
Este ha sido nuestro último vídeo de una
serie especial sobre las amenazas a las que
se enfrenta Estados Unidos: desde los proble
mas del pentágono, a la guerra con el Yuan,
pasando por Irán o Corea del Norte.
Os dejo el enlace a esta lista de reproducción
en la descripción.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Crees que en Washington se empezarán a
tomar este problema en serio?
¿Qué harías tu para solucionarlo?
¿Se arreglarán las cosas por sí solas?
¿Cómo terminará toda esta historia?
Como siempre, déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.